the Yale veteran Community is truly
amazing and I think that's because the
administration here makes it feel like
veterans really belong at
[Music]
Yale hi my name is Michaela cardillo I'm
a third-year student at y Law School I
served 5 years in the Navy as a surface
Warfare officer I went to the Naval
Academy right out of high school I
wanted to do something that was greater
than myself but then also sort of see
the world outside of my hometown in
Indiana Veterans Day is a time to
reflect on the sacrifice that veterans
Have Made for This country we all took
an oath to defend American ideals and we
all took that with an understanding that
we could possibly give our lives for
those ideals people are grateful your
country is grateful for your service in
the sacrifices that you
[Music]
made